Take a brief moment to think back to your
younger years, spending long, tiresome hours
trapped in a classroom, waiting to hear the
noise of that final bell of the day.
That sound meant freedom, the end of another
grueling six hours at your desk, and the chance
to get back to the warm sanctuary of home.
If you were lucky, you might not have had
to go far to get back to the safety and security
of being in your parents’ house, living
close enough to the school would mean you
could easily walk home when the day was through.
But your classmates?
Well, they weren’t all as lucky, some of
them had miles to travel, all the way across
town even.
Fortunately, though, the school bus would
always be waiting outside at the end of each
day, ready to take a gaggle of rowdy kids
back home.
And if you were one of those kids that had
to take the bus, you’ll know that the trip
home after school was hardly a calm drive.
Paper planes and spitballs firing from all
directions, wads of chewing gum stuck to the
undersides of the seats, other kids all around
you screaming and yelling at the top of their
lungs.
Still, it could be worse, right?
No, trust us, it could be much, much worse
than you can ever imagine.
What if, one day, the bus that picked you
up from school wasn’t a bus at all?
What if, instead, it was SCP-2086?
Picture this: One day, you get put in detention
at school.
Maybe you were disrupting a class or got caught
spraying graffiti on the outside wall of the
gym.
Whatever the reason, we’re sure you think
it’s unfair that you got held back after
school, after everyone else had already gone
home.
But you do your time, until finally, you’re
told you can leave.
Problem is, your house is on the other side
of town, and you’ve already missed the bus.
You make your way off the campus, down the
nearest street.
Maybe there’s a city bus you can catch that’ll
get you home.
As you stroll away from your school, you realize
that the nearest bus stop, the first one on
the route home, seems to be further away than
you remember it being.
Must just be the exhaustion of a long day
getting the better of you, playing tricks
on your mind.
It’s not like someone could move the bus
stop, right?
Finally reaching the stop, you notice lights
coming down the street after a few moments
of waiting quietly.
A late bus, just like you hoped for.
It pulls up next to the stop, the doors folding
open to allow you on board.
It’s totally empty, save for the driver.
But straight away, you notice there’s something
odd about him.
He seems drained of color, his movements are
weird, more like a puppet on strings than
an actual living, breathing human being.
Now you think about it, if it wasn’t for
the fact he was clearly moving, driving the
bus, you might assume that he was a corpse.
Then again, maybe he just had a long day too.
Taking a seat, you try not to think about
it, and stare out of the window in boredom.
You watch as the route takes you past stop
after stop, all of them empty just like the
bus itself.
But then something unexpected happens.
You’ve ridden the bus to and from school
so many times before that you can’t help
but notice when, for some reason, it takes
a wrong turn.
Looking out the window you know you aren’t
mistaken.
The driver has changed direction, instead
of heading towards the nearest stop to home,
he’s taken the bus towards the furthest
edge of town.
Desperately you try yelling at him, asking
why he’s taken the wrong turn, but the driver
stays still, as if he can’t even hear what
you’re saying.
That’s when you notice the smell.
You didn’t catch it before, but now it’s
all around you, filling the air inside the
bus.
It’s almost like the scent of disinfectant;
the bus now smells the same way a hospital
does.
But that’s not all.
The more you breathe it in, the more you feel
yourself starting to get woozy, arms and legs
getting heavier.
Everything around you feels as if it’s spinning
uncontrollably.
Out of the windows, you can just about make
out the sight of a junkyard, blurring in and
out of focus.
It’s meant to be abandoned, and yet you’re
sure you can see movement: Massive, indeterminate
shapes shifting around in the dark.
Finally, your vision goes dark and you fall
unconscious onto the floor of the bus.
Only you were never on the bus to begin with.
No, although you didn’t know it, you were
prey to something that just looked like a
bus: SCP-2086.
And now that it’s caught you, you’ll never
see the light of day again.
Now, SCP-2086 doesn’t just refer to a single
creature, not by a long shot.
It’s the designation given to an entire
species of arthropods; think lobsters, crabs,
and spiders, or insects like centipedes and
millipedes.
Only much bigger.
To the untrained eye, and depending on when
you look, an instance of SCP-2086 will normally
look like any ordinary public transport vehicle,
of any make and model, or belonging to any
company or transit authority.
Usually, though, they look like regular old
buses, at least while they’re out foraging
for food.
When born, an SCP-2086 specimen will grow
to full juvenile size within a week, usually
weighing two hundred kilograms or less.
Fully matured adult instances, however, can
weigh approximately seventeen thousand kilograms.
The adults are the ones that go out foraging,
leaving the nest to collect food to then bring
back to the juvenile SCP-2086s.
And by food, we of course mean humans.
While out on the roads, matured SCP-2086 creatures
are practically identical to the auto vehicles
that form their bodies.
But the materials that this disguise is made
from – the steel, plastic, wood, and glass
– they’re all actually comprised of specialized
chitin, the kind of outer shell you’ll find
on most arthropods.
But underneath that outer shell, that’s
where you’ll find the real horror.
Within the main chamber, beneath the flooring
of the bus’s long, inner portion, is stored
the pulsing, beating heart of an SCP-2086
specimen.
And we don’t mean that in a metaphorical
sense, if you were to lift up the floorboards
of one of these bus-like creatures you’d
see its heart, along with other vital organs
like the creature’s brain and stomach.
What’s more, that figure in the front seat,
that you thought was a living, breathing bus
driver, actually isn’t living or breathing,
not anymore.
Preserved in a shellac substance that the
creature is able to produce, this driver is
actually a human corpse, acting as a decoy
for SCP-2086s.
From within the bus body, fibrous appendages
reach up into the corpse, almost like incredibly
thin hairs.
The creature can then use the cadaver essentially
as a puppet, a puppet with a dead person’s
body.
That’s how an SCP-2086 is able to move its
driver around, making it appear more lifelike
so it can lure its prey aboard.
Think of it like the bioluminescent light
that anglerfish use to tempt unsuspecting
fish into their jaws.
Same principle, but with a dramatically different
result when it comes to SCP-2086.
But if you thought bus creatures with internal
organs under the floor and dead meat puppets
in the driver’s seat weren’t creepy enough,
there’s still much more to SCP-2086s than
meets the eye.
For example, when they aren’t out foraging,
the adult creatures can unravel the roof of
their bus-shaped outer shell.
Underneath is a pair of wings, large enough
and strong enough to carry their entire, several
thousand kilos of weight off the ground and
up into the air.
As for eyes?
The headlights at the front are, in actual
fact, bioluminescent optical organs, allowing
the creatures to see their prey even in the
dark.
Still not horrifying enough?
Well, would knowing about their legs help?
The wheels underneath an SCP-2086 specimen
are also capable of unraveling, forming long,
grey, or black legs, like those of a spider.
Yes, these are bus creatures with wings and
multi-jointed legs.
These legs aren’t just big, clumsy appendages
either.
Compared with other arthropods, SCP-2086s
are able to use their limbs to perform surprisingly
intricate actions and finer levels of manipulations.
For instance, a number of specimens have been
observed in the wild, by the SCP Foundation,
building shelters out of any materials that
they can find near their nesting ground.
And where do they normally nest?
Wherever there’s plenty of scrap metal,
and hardly any people to notice them.
Junkyards are the preferred habitats of SCP-2086s,
and where they will normally establish their
colonies.
While the juveniles remain within the confines
of the colony, adult SCP-2086 specimens will
leave to collect humans.
Although, on occasion, the younger specimens
have been known to travel out from their nest
and rearrange or relocate signposts for bus
stops.
They then place them in a route that leads
back towards their nesting ground; it’s
something worth remembering if your nearest
bus stop ever seems to be a little further
away from the school than usual.
Afterward, the older specimens will travel
along the route laid out by the juvenile SCP-2086s,
picking up any human passengers that they
find waiting at the relocated bus stops.
They have to choose their moments wisely,
with people boarding and disembarking from
the bus usually every few stops.
Once an SCP-2086 has as many humans on board
as it can carry, with the certainty it won’t
lose any at the upcoming stop, it secretes
a substance similar to chloroform.
This fills the inner chamber of the bus, causing
that noxious smell, like hospital disinfectant.
The chloroform-like substance incapacitates
all the passengers on board, rendering them
unconscious and readying them to be taken
back to the local SCP-2086 colony.
Once the adult SCP-2086 has arrived at the
junkyard, the juveniles will descend on it.
Given their much, much smaller size, they
will climb inside the mature specimen and
forcibly remove each and every human passenger
it is carrying within.
Then comes the truly nasty part: feeding time.
Each juvenile SCP-2086 will force their captive
human through an orifice that is located under
the front hood of their vehicle shell.
This sphincter, a circular formation of muscle
that can expand and contract to perform a
bodily function, is connected to where the
steering wheel is found on an adult SCP-2086.
The younger creatures will push their human
prey through this sphincter, consuming them.
Once this has occurred, those hairy appendages
in the driver’s seat will then latch onto
the body of the now-dead human, piercing through
their skin, winding up and around their bones.
These are the same fibrous hairs used to puppet
the deceased corpse and use it to lure others
aboard the bus, but these appendages have
another function: they’re feeding tubes.
They will drain every last drop of blood from
the SCP-2086’s prey, until the body is little
more than a husk.
At which point, the tubes inject a saline
solution directly into the cadaver.
Afterwards, the inside of the bus fills with
that same substance that preserves the corpse,
and the process is complete.
As horrifying as these creatures are, one
of the few upsides of SCP-2086s is that they
don’t live very long.
Female specimens will reproduce after eight
days, and produce twenty offspring after this
point.
Each of these newborns reaches full maturity
and size in about a week.
On average, SCP-2086s live for twelve to fifteen
days.
Another net positive is, because of their
short lifespans, an SCP-2086 specimen doesn’t
need to feed on a human more than once, as
the nutrients it absorbs as a juvenile are
enough to sustain it through adulthood.
Once it has matured, an SCP-2086 will go out
into the nearest city or town to forage for
humans, providing food to the next generation.
And so, the cycle continues.
In the future, rather than take the bus, maybe
it’s safer to walk.
It might mean the difference between you making
it home, or becoming food.
Now go check out “The Skin Stealers - SCP-3333
- Tower” and “SCP-2521 ●●|●●●●●|●●|● and
Infohazard SCPs Explained” for more of the
weirdest anomalous monsters out there!